donc c'est un appel au secours que je
vous fais aujourd'hui pour en avoir
discuté avec les infirmières les
aid-soignantes les agents de régulation
médicale la du Samu 31 mais conférences
de l'hôpital public et du privé vous
prendre des gardes de régulation mais
son frère Messenger de ville et mes
collègues spécialistes nous sommes tous
épuisés physiquement et nerveusement
alors j'ai pas de solution miracle il
est certain que la situation actuelle ne
peut plus continuer un médecin
généraliste débordé les urgences une
consultation spécialité débordée les
urgences un désert médical les urgences
un cabinet fermé les urgences des délais
de rendez-vous allongés les urgences un
centre de 15 débordé les urgences et les
urgences font ce qu'elles font depuis
des années parce que ce que j'appelle
pour rigoler les 3T tout tout le temps
tout de suite
pour faire de la médecine il faut des
médecins des infirmières des aides
soignants des ash comme un hôtel public
nous faisons face à des vagues
d'émission et pour en avoir 10
longuement discuté avec elle puisque
surtout des infirmières elle traque perd
toujours plus avec toujours moins ce
n'est plus possible vous donner un ordre
d'idée j'exerce une petite ville au sud
de Toulouse une petite clinique avec 200
lits d'hospitalisations le service des
urgences accueille 36000 personnes par
an quand nous l'avons ouvert il y a 23
ans on a commencé il y avait 6000
personnes qui venaient tous les ans une
progression significative il y a six
médecins qui veulent entendre nous
sommes de la journée tout seul la nuit
de médecine d'urgence nous sommes passés
à de la médecine de catastrophes avec un
afflux massif de blessés sauf que c'est
une catastrophe permanente le flux ne
s'arrête jamais il peut ralentir un
petit peu la nuit mais ne s'arrête
jamais nous avons des équipes épuisées
et pourtant Dieu sait que nous aimons
essayer d'en prendre soin comme l’ont
déjà dit mes confrères nous sommes nous
aussi confrontés au poids d'une
administration
je voulais dire folle c'est pas très
gentil de formulaire de protocoles de
réunioni de référentiel de normes
chronophages et sans intérêt réel pour
le cœur de notre métier le patient le
soir
depuis des années le système essaie
désespérément me faire rentrer la
médecine dans des cases et comme cela
est impossible on tape fort mais un
carré n'est jamais rentré dans un rond
cela fait des années que nous tirons la
sonnette d'alarme et chaque année nous
arrivons nous y arrivions nous passions
la périodes hivernale qui est
classiquement la plus rude en 2017
l'épidémie des griffes fut plus
importante que d'habitude et je me
souviens partir travailler la boule au
ventre un service plein des ambulances
qui continuellement d'arriver sans aucun
libre brancard pour les accueillir
c'est-à-dire nous allons nous risquons
d'avoir la grippe et le covid et je
crains que nous ne passions pas nous
sommes débordés submergement à tous les
niveaux le CMU dans sa partie régulation
fait face à des volumes d'appel
ingérables j'étais dimanche dernier nous
avons fini la journée à plus de 1700
dossiers des tentateurs après décrocher
et avant les régulations qui sont montés
à 1h40 1h40 de musique c'est le rond et
quand il y a trop d'appels trop de temps
d'attente on régule un peu moins bien on
en voit vers les urgences c'est normal
ça m'est arrivé à moi aussi on en a trop
aller aux urgences
les demandes faites par le président de
la FHF au médecin libéraux de reporter
leurs congés de fin d'année ou le
directeur de l'AP-HP de racheter des
périodes de congés pour quelques
milliers d'euros
ressemblent à une manœuvre de cavalerie
effectivement aussi sur la fonctionner
pour qu'elle quelques semaines les
guerres plus
et comme je le disais plus haut pour
faire de la médecine il faut des
médecins et des soignants
une étude récente montre que 50% des
médecins sont au bord du burn-out mais
confrères ont beaucoup se désengagent et
Cher des activités moins intenses
psychologiquement parlant alors pour en
parler je le dis toujours en plaisantant
je suis là le énième revêtant d'une
vieille dynastie médicale toulousaine
c'est à dire que quand on parlait de
médecine vivent avec un père professeur
d'université un angle professeur
d'université un grand oncle un
grand-père un arrière-grand-père il faut
quand même le plus ancien était né
c'était à la fin du 18e si vous dire si
j'ai baigne dedans depuis quelques temps
déjà j'ai donc vu évoluer la médecine et
les médecins le système de vie de 2021
on place depuis quelques années à réussi
à faire disparaître la sérénité chez le
médecin et c'est important à sérénité
lorsque vous remettez votre diplôme et
votre vie en jeu à chaque patient
lorsque le risque médico-légal devient
fou cela vous amène à faire je ne dirais
pas une mauvaise médecine mais nous
finissons et cet humain par penser par
moments plus à nous qu'à nos patients
l'heure est grave toute notre système de
soins est au bord de l'implosion et ce
n'est une figure de style nous sommes
tous en train d'y laisser notre peau
parce que je prends ma garde et que je
récupère des confrères en larmes et des
infirmières on pleure ce n’est pas
normal standing d'un pays comme le nôtre
je n'accable personne mais c'est les
résultats de 40 ans de politique de
santé basés sur une gestion industrielle
de la médecine il n'y a pas d'économie
d'échelle en médecine les groupes les
gros hôpitaux de réalisent que très peu
d'économies d'échelle vraiment à la mort
et on ne gère pas un hôpital comme une
usine de petits pois il faut des humains
pour des humains et maintenant il va
falloir s'occuper des soignants et c'est
une priorité absolue sans soignant il a
plus de médecine et les drames sont à
venir il y a quelques mois je discutais
avec le directeur du Samu 31 le
professeur Boon à la suite de d'une
récrimination des des pompiers sur le
fait que certains médecins urgentistes
n'avaient pas été aimable avec leurs
objectifs la question combien de fois
cela est-il arrivé la réponse a été une
fois par mois soit 12 fois par an sur
36000 passages et c'est comme pour le
pourcentage d'erreur du Samu 31 qui doit
être la même dans tous les Samus de
France peu de choses près ce pourcentage
c'est de 4 pour 1000 ça veut dire 99,6%
de succès pas mal quand même mais non on
regarde les quatre fourmis les 12 fois
par an ou l'urgentiste épuisé un mot de
travers on peut faire une guerre une
erreur de régulation ce qui nous est
tous arrivé regardons ce qui fonctionne
prenons soin des médecins favorisant les
passerelles on peut le public et le
privé des cloisonnons simplifions et
redonnons le pouvoir à ceux qui savent
la Société de Médecine d'Urgence le
fameux dessur avec un exercice exclusif
en service d'urgence des médecins
informés à l'urgence absolue les CCM 4
et 5 qui représentent un petit peu moins
de 2% des passages d'un exemple de la
fausse bonne idée
les 98% restants je veux bien mais qui
va le faire il va faire des futurs qui
va faire des plâtres qui va s'occuper de
ces gens il y a personne d'autre la nuit
à partir de minuit il y a plus que nous
l'ouvrir il y a plus de permanence de
son ambulatoire il y a plus un message
généraliste de garde le seul truc ouvert
c'est les urgences donc un urgentistes
vous nous sommes des médecins
généralistes on fait tout on fait de du
rhume jusqu'à l'infarctus à l'embolie
pulmonaire ou à l'AVC
donc nous allons avoir besoin de toutes
les bonnes volontés la formation des
internes doit également se faire dans le
privé un stage c'est pas énorme mais à
terme cela rendra plus fluide les
discussions publiques privées sera
disparaître les inimitiés dû à une
méconnaissance du travail de l'autre
même métier même serment même patient
utilisons mieux les compétences
optimisons les ressources disponibles il
y en a encore un tout petit peu une
direction comme la
décrétée la loi HPST totalement
administrative ne fonctionne pas ne
fonctionnera jamais administration doit
au service des médecins et des soignants
pas l'inverse et pour conclure je
réitère un appel au secours pour
l'ensemble des médecins et personnels
soignants de ce pays nous sommes à bout
donc en train de craquer toutes formes
contraintes supplémentaires ne fera
qu'augmenter l'hémorragie de compétence
comme vous le savez reste long à
remplacer remettons du bon sens de
l'humanité et de la gentillesse arrêtez
de nous transformer en machine à soigner
cela ne marche pas et de nous à être à
continuer à être fidèle à notre serment
[Musique]